Now, if we put all of this knowledge together and just look at the problems that are in NP
then there's a lot of different possibilities for the properties of that problem.
So either the problem if it's an NP could be in P or this NP complete
or it might even be something else.
Now, we haven't really talked about this something else here, but they are some problems,
which are believed to be somewhere in between P and NP at least if P does not equal NP, of course.
One example here, for example, would be factoring two large numbers.
Now, if your problem is NP complete, there are still very very many possibilities.
Your problem could be fixed-parameter tractable.
Your problem could have an approximation algorithm
and that approximation algorithm might either be a PTAS, a constant-factor approximation algorithm,
or also something else, and again, we haven't really talked about this something else,
but for example, there are some approximation algorithms where you can have a
logarithmic approximation factor and then there are randomized algorithms,
Monte Carlo algorithms and Las Vegas algorithms, and there are many many other things
that we haven't touched upon so really a lot of different complexities.
Now, one final thing I should mention, they are two notions here
especially if you talked to somebody who has studied theoretical computer science.
They will nitpick you about the NP completeness, because NP completeness
is technically only defined for decision problems.
So if you're talking about optimization problems and you want to be very correct
then you should call that problem an NP hard problem.
But many people use this term interchangeably, and actually, when you are working in practice
on hard problems, it doesn't really make much of a difference at least in my opinion,
but it is not the most precise way to say it so decision problems,
NP complete, optimization problems, NP hard.
What would happen if we were able to show that P equals NP?
Would then each single class we have shown here become P? Or would the classes separate?
And what I mean by this is could be then showed that not every NP complete problem
is fixed-parameter tractable or not every NP complete problem has an approximation algorithm.
And more than one of these here can be correct.